since the dawn of humanity an estimated
100 point 8 billion people have lived
and died a number that increases by
about point 8 percent of the world's
population each year what happens to all
of those people's bodies after they die
and will the planet eventually run out
of burial space when a person's heart
stops beating the body passes through
several stages before it begins
decomposing within minutes after death
the blood begins settling in the lower
most parts of the body usually eight to
twelve hours later the skin in those
areas is discolored by livor mortis or
post-mortem stain and while at the
moment of death the body's muscles
relaxed completely in a condition called
primary flaccidity they stiffen about
two to six hours later in what's known
as a rigor mortis this stiffening
spreads through the muscles and its
speed can be affected by age gender and
the surrounding environment the body
also changes temperature usually cooling
off to match its environment
next comes decomposition the process by
which bacteria and insects break apart
the body many factors affect the rate of
decomposition there is however a basic
guide of the effect of the environment
on decomposition called caspere's law it
says that if all other factors are equal
a body exposed to air decomposes twice
as fast as one immersed in water and
eight times as fast as one buried in
earth soil acidity also greatly affects
bone preservation high acidity soils
with a pH of less than five point three
will rapidly decompose bone whereas in a
neutral or basic soil with a pH of seven
or more a skeleton can remain in
relatively good condition for centuries
different cultures throughout history
have developed unique approaches to
burials as far back as the first
neanderthal burials death was
accompanied by rituals like the position
coloring or decorating of corpses
traditional Christian burials decorate
the body and dress while in traditional
Islam a body is wrapped in a piece of
ritual fabric with the face oriented
toward Mecca traditional Hindus
ceremonially burn the body and
zoroastrians followers of one of the
oldest monotheistic religions
traditionally placed bodies atop a tower
to expose them to the Sun and scavenging
Birds before the Industrial Revolution
burials were simple and accessible these
days with suitable burial and running
out in high population areas purchasing
private grave sites can be costly and
many people can't afford simple burials
even cremation the second most common
burial practice in the world comes with
a high cost as for the question of
running out of space the issue isn't so
much about total land in the world as it
is that large populations cluster
together within cities most of the big
cities in the world may run out of
suitable burial grounds within a century
for London it's even sooner that may
happen by 2035 so are there alternatives
to traditional burials that might help
with the space issue in some countries
skyscraper cemeteries enable vertical
burials some options focus on the body's
relationship with the environment
promotion for example frees dries and
pulverizes the body creating a powder
that can turn into compost when mixed
with oxygen and water there are also
green burials that use special materials
such as biodegradable caskets urns that
sprout trees and burial suits that grow
mushrooms eternal reefs take that
concept to the depths of the ocean using
a mixture of ashes and cement to create
marine habitats for sea life death is an
inevitable part of the human condition
but how we treat bodies and burials
continues to evolve we may each have
different spiritual religious or
practical approaches to dying but the
ever-increasing demand for burial space
might give us a push to be creative
about where our bodies go after
the final stages of life
you